[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
what is going on right now is people who
don't want to compete want to get things
without competing not straight across
the board yeah i'm talking about white
women
they they have my [ __ ] that's what i'm
talking about
they don't want to compete they want to
wind their way into something
oh my god you get my [ __ ] award in
there still crying
my wife was watching the [ __ ] emmys
what do you got your own show and they
gave you a little statue
you're still crying what else can we do
to make you happy
it's [ __ ] unbelievable people of
color i get
well i don't understand being a white
woman in the united states it's not as
hard as that
it can't be it can't be dude the metoo
movement has killed the [ __ ]
my wife will not suck my dick on her
knees ever again
never will happen because your stomach
is pushing down her [ __ ] neck
happy wife happy life oh those guys are
done i watch whatever tv she wants to
watch
i'm envious of them are you those
because they have the
smoothest [ __ ] life never lose their
house
they're just like just stay like a
[ __ ] uh
you know those big doorman buildings
where i got a package for you mr rogers
like you become that in the relationship
you should just say we're like the bell
cap and something like that
you know what i mean yes those life are
dormant yeah first time i had a
sexuality she goes
we're getting close to the end she goes
do you want to come on my face and i was
like
not originally but i guess now i do i
don't want to be the one guy that didn't
and so you took it as a challenge and
then next thing you know it's like
that's my thing
and then you go to the next girl and
she's like what the [ __ ] you do you're
like
oh sorry i i'm only i'm i'm i only speak
the language of the last person
so i'm trying to translate into you it's
a bold move dude
that's a bold move where are you going
and you're over oh i thought it was cool
wiping it off with your sleeve sorry
do you hate me do you hate me now you
own it and then you play the victim
then you play the victim or not you hate
me great i mean i can't do anything
i mean everything you're leaving your
shoes don't come on my face i mean
i'm on the corner of the bed naked you
start eating
well next the fat has nowhere to hide it
just doesn't it just it's like
it's just over all right you come back
on this show
and i'm gonna be skinny and i'm gonna
call it the the bill burr
ethan's no longer fat no here's the
thing i gave you like literally i just
scraped the surface
okay and what you want to do is get a
nutritionist do not listen to your
listeners who's going to be actually you
do do this
about almond milk and it's going to be a
zillion things yeah
that's why i got a nutritionist because
if you go on and you try to learn
yourself
on the internet and you don't know what
you're doing just
the first like three pages
are all dominated by evil food people
yeah it's just like yeah you know you're
not getting away and it's just
and then trying to it's like trying to
give money to a charity right how the
[ __ ] do i know
that this is a legit one so how do i
know
it's just so okay i think i do need to
get a nutritionist i agree
but you know i tried a diet where i got
a personal trainer and she's like i want
you to eat
high fat ground beef cheese
avocado i was like are you sure this is
going to make me lose weight yeah that
what
and then what it's like the uh no [ __ ]
out of [ __ ]
i was like what's your blog i was like
what are you talking about
what is that that's the uh
i think that they do is a lot of those
personal trainers what they have is they
have down
to like a formula how to have you do
like a biggest loser
weight drop mm-hmm and like how to
quickly just cut things down yeah
look amazing bloodline yeah i don't like
i really it's not sustainable
yeah you can't that's not out yeah she
scared the hell out of me when she was
like
everything you just said i'm like how is
this going to move through my body yeah
yeah what what is the lubricant where is
the what is going to get me
oh well you drink a stick of butter okay
and i know there's a lot of lies about
nutrition because that that just goes
too far yeah i think we all can
understand
take a handful of raw bacon and dunk it
in butter juice
everything was a lie that you were told
it's just like all right it's just like
this is either 100 right or i'm going to
jonestown
they don't want a real job contractors
oh yeah oh the gate guy
the sauna guy that this guy that guy
they all got their little [ __ ] then
the handyman guys
yeah well i grew up with those guys
because i my dad was an architect
so i did construction from the time i
was in high school all all throughout
the summer i was always doing
side jobs i always had jobs on
construction sites as a laborer
oh yeah carpenter's assistance i was
always around those guys i tried to do
that i lasted eight days
i just with my [ __ ] fair skin we were
doing roofing in july and it was just i
just remember
my job was i was putting in the
scaffolding going around you know when
you you [ __ ] drill the hole
then you put the triangle thing and then
you [ __ ] put the bolt on and the
irish guy kept going billy you must work
quicker you much more quickly that's
what he kept saying to me
and i finally stuck my head out the side
of the house i was like dude i've done
this for three days if you want me to
[ __ ] go quicker
you know we were like literally three
stories up and he finally shut the [ __ ]
up
he must be a non-union guy uh oh yeah
dude i remember there was a [ __ ] guy
on the site i swear to god he wore the
same [ __ ] jeans
every day with like no underwear right
and it had a [ __ ]
giant [ __ ] hole right here on his
thigh
so i'm in [ __ ] working in the house
and i just remember
he stepped over something with his left
leg and the whole [ __ ] hole
moved right just like flashed his
[ __ ] junk
i was just like and i didn't know how to
stand up to people
and plus you know i was the new guy on
the thing and i just was
wanted to be like buddy how about you
put on some [ __ ] boxers or something
so i don't get to look at your [ __ ]
first of all he's walking around with
like a goddamn nail gun not like boxers
could stop that but any extra layer of
clothing
that you could have this guy's literally
like his [ __ ] [ __ ] you know like an
owl looking out of a tree
i lived with two lesbians in new york
and i i was fresh out of college i
didn't know anything about
anything oh god diverse can i watch you
two get it on well i have my shirt off
what did i say and then i come on your
face no
that's not cool i paid half my rent
technically why am i paying half if you
[ __ ] you should be a third and third
if i'm paying 50 i gotta be able to see
the two you go down on each other
and then they flipped out i thought i
would come home and they'd be wrestling
in sports bras just
and it was just they just fell in love
like regular roommates that
it was annoying as [ __ ] they're like
this baby won eggs baby likes eggs
the whole [ __ ] time there's been
[ __ ] [ __ ] on my street
walking around no masks you know not
quarantining like the people that come
by the houses you see the [ __ ]
you know the same people that were going
in and out of the house who are not part
of their family still going in and out
of the house you want people to walk
down the street with a mask on
let's not start this job do you though
let's not start this okay
let's start i don't want to start this
[ __ ] i'm not going to sit here with
no medical degree
listening to you with no medical degree
with an american flag behind you smoking
a cigar
acting like we know what's up better
than the cdc
all i do is i list i watch the news once
every two weeks i'm like
mascara no mess still mask all right
mass that's all i give a [ __ ] about
i don't care but even they say you
shouldn't wear a mask unless you're
treating a coronavirus patient the world
health organization yeah they didn't say
that initial they didn't say it
initially no they didn't they did and
then it gradually then it grabbed and
then wait wait look and then everybody
wore the [ __ ] masks
this is like rollerblading everybody
[ __ ] rollerbladed and then there was
that one [ __ ] homophobic joke and
then everybody acted like they never did
it
and then a hundred million [ __ ]
rollerblades got thrown into the [ __ ]
ocean we all wore math
and then all of a sudden people are
[ __ ] sitting there what you don't
have the body type for it dude
your [ __ ] knuckles would scrape on
the ground
even with that extra two inches
i just love how wearing a mask became
like this [ __ ]
like soft thing that you were doing like
being courteous being courteous why is
it for [ __ ] that's
so stupid first of all
oh god you're so tough with your [ __ ]
open nose and throat
joe and your five o'clock shadow this is
a man right here a man doesn't wear a
mask
why does it always become like that it's
always like the man
what do men do we make fun of things
anything anything that uh seems like
you're not taking chances
right that's what you don't have that's
the problem with that unless you were
already wearing the mask and then you're
acting like you didn't then all of a
sudden people watch your thing
and then they all pile up oh look at
this [ __ ] wearing the masks like
you were [ __ ] doing it two weeks ago
well i was scared out of my mind in the
beginning
in the beginning like when the first
when when everybody's shutting down the
beginning and
people are stockpiling food i was
convinced i was like jesus christ dude
you have like nine elk in your basement
you were you were the one person i knew
was fine tom pop is making bread
i knew i knew he was what i was worried
about i was worried about people i knew
getting really sick and dying
and then i was convinced that i had it
at one point i was like
i do feel like i'm breathing heavy i
feel like
my breath is something like my breath is
coming short
i did i did i like had like
psychosomatic issues
thinking about it
i had a [ __ ] panic attack sitting on
[ __ ] 12 elk
you had a [ __ ] panic attack then you
felt bad about yourself
and then you attack people with mass
that's how it works that's how the
hatred starts and that's right now
why seven blocks of seattle you can't go
now
[Music]
[Music]
like across
ain't no right way just the wrong way